[Music]
gene
is with us in lexington kentucky hi gene
how are you
hi dave thanks for taking my call sure
um
i i have a question i am going to
receive a nice inheritance
approximately 175 000 uh
i would like to keep this in my name so
that my children can be the
beneficiaries
i'd also like to hold it in case my
mother needs
uh more money for her care
in the next couple years and i'd like to
keep this
just private in that uh
my husband doesn't know a lot about this
uh what would you suggest i do
gene we need we gotta do honey we gotta
dig into that why
why why why do we not want the husband
to know
um just a precarious relationship
there's never been any respect
for my family and i really don't want
him to
have any part of this should it happen
so um you know
that's the way it is been that way for a
long time so how long you've been
married
over 50 years
okay um
i don't think it is i don't think it is
healthy to hide things from spouses
i don't think it's healthy for you i
don't think it's healthy for him
um if you want to set it aside where
uh he doesn't have any access to it
uh that's very possible and um
you know you can but but you know not
telling him about
it is uh that's not good that's
deceiving and you don't want you don't
be that person
and i'm not going to participate in
helping you do that because i think
that's wrong
but um i know oh that i just knew that
um uh
you know i don't think he would let me
handle
it or you know have it he doesn't have a
choice
yeah this this language is what's
concerning gene i mean i know you have
been married a long time and it sounds
like there's been
layers of problems for a long time but
the he won't let me with this money that
you're getting
for your family i i don't how old are
you
i'm over 70. okay
all right well what i would tell you to
do is to
contact an estate planning attorney and
talk about how you can put this into
a trust of some kind that
you are in control of and it's really
not
up to him he doesn't have a let you part
in this
except that he emotionally rules over
you it sounds like
um but you know what this is pointing
out is
that you don't have a precarious
relationship you have a horrible
relationship that's what this is
pointing out you don't
trust your husband yeah and you don't
feel safe
with him yeah i mean that's that's not
trying to exaggerate it but you don't
feel safe to tell him
something that is happening in your life
and
for fear that he's going to quote take
over right he's not going to let you
take care of your mom from a legal and
a account perspective he doesn't really
have control
it comes the check would come to you you
open up an account
uh you you set it in a trust um
you can put in a simple bank account if
you want to but it's in your name he has
absolutely no access to it now you're
going to want to be sure you have a will
so that the money goes to your children
as you said
and that he doesn't get any control of
it that the trust
and that's one reason to set it up as a
trust then the trust can transfer to
your children
um and there's you know it's almost
impossible for him to break into that
with a will if you have a will and a
trust and the money's in trust
and it's you know you're the trustee
it's in control you're in control of it
or somebody's a trustee you're the
beneficiary whatever
however your estate planner tells you to
set it up but you need to go see an
estate planning attorney
and you're going to spend three to five
thousand dollars on documents
a will a trust and you're going to get
some legal advice
on how to do this uh in a way where it
all stays in your name where you're in
complete control of it
but he doesn't have any legal access to
this money
unless you give it to him and so uh
but but honey you got other stuff going
on here
there's a lot of fish frying on this one
on this one discussion
and you know this is not really about
the hundred seventy-five thousand this
is about the quality of your life
well this one's gonna ask would you
recommend counseling i mean they've been
married
50 years like it's kind of like not like
it's like too far gone but it's like
are peop do you think he would even be
open to
i have no idea i mean i it it couldn't
hurt
right but it's like to your point you i
mean you don't need to live your wife
this way gene you don't need to live in
fear whether it's about a
an inheritance conversation or anything
that you don't need to live like that
like you
there needs to be these issues i would
love to see you get help with them
get him to get help with them no doesn't
matter if you've been married if you're
in
your church you ought to sit down with
your pastor and have this discussion
yeah
with or without him yeah and and then
but as far as the
you know uh you shouldn't have from a
legal perspective
uh he has absolutely no access to the
money
unless you give it to him if you do what
i'm talking about
now if you just go open up a bank
account um
you know you can get into all kinds of
different issues then so i'm going to
say let's put it in the trust
and let's have a let's have a uh a will
and then that'll
dictate what happens to the money yeah
gene i would i would
yeah i if if there's something you
didn't say
where you don't want to tell him because
you're scared to tell him for more
you need to get you need to have some
you know some help some support
through this if there's if there's
something where you're scared to
to tell him for other reasons you just
you need to have some extra support
through this amen in case there's
something you didn't say
yeah absolutely so yeah yeah you need to
sit down with your pastor this week
and and let's get some stuff let's get
some people around you and figure out
what the flip's really going on here
i am still stuck with the 70 plus year
old lady in lexington
who is in obviously a very dysfunctional
marriage
yeah been married 50 years yeah like
this is not like this is a new thing
yeah and and i think um
so anytime i can find somebody that is
in a
a bad situation particularly
late in life what i want to learn from
that
if i'm in this audience listening to
this is how to not end up there
like i mean if you talk to somebody
who's in their 70s they have zero money
it's a bad situation right they're
living off social security social
insecurity right
starving to death because that's no
picnic
then i want to learn how not to be that
person so how do you not
end up there yeah where she is
yeah you know i think what's interesting
and you've talked about this before
in any area of life life choices that
type of thing i don't think it's this
um i don't think it's an overnight thing
i don't think it's one of those things
it's some tragedy or some
you flip a switch it's by degrees by
degrees
we make bad choices by degrees we settle
by degrees we compromise by degrees we
let someone have power over us by
degrees we let things go don't set
boundaries don't communicate
by degrees and you wake up one day i'm
just guessing here
on this call for example and you make a
statement
that sounds totally normal to you i
can't tell him because he won't let me
do that with my money and that sounds
normal to you
because by degrees over 50 years there
have become these grooves in your
relationship
of what has been allowed what has been
acceptable what has been permitted
that you are in this very unhealthy
dynamic very unhealthy roles
but i don't think it started that way i
don't think they were like that when
they walked on the aisle i wouldn't
imagine
you know no but you know
some things you know your wealth your
health
your relationships your
leadership your business your career
there there is no such thing as status
quo nothing stays the same
it is growing or it's dying and
typically if it's growing it's a matter
of you've been intentional about it
if it's dying it's because you you know
your garden if your garden is full of
weeds it's because you let it go
no one said oh let's intentionally fill
the garden full of weeds
right but you just let it go right you
didn't do anything
if you want a a beautiful rose garden
you know you've got to put the manure
down you got it you got to do the
trimmings you got to you got to do the
cuttings you have to uh prune
the dead wood away and you have to weed
and so a series of constant incremental
intentional acts
cause you to grow and become better
and better and better and better in a
given area of your life
or relationships not doing that it just
deteriorates
so as you said it didn't start out in
the place she is
but you know so
what i want folks to take from that call
is um we used to have a guy work here he
said sometimes people like that are an
anti-mentor
they're the opposite of a mentor this is
what not to do
okay so what not to do is to
35 years ago not have dealt with it
whatever it is right and um
you know it because it you know i you
know i'll just i'm just not gonna worry
about it well then your guard's gonna
have weeds
do you think there's something do you
think there's a generational thing i'm
sure there's a value thing
with this maybe it's personality style
whatever where it's this idea of like
i'm gonna sweep it under the rug because
that's the be the bigger person
i'm going to take the higher ground it's
the polite southern godly christian
thing to do
i've told matt before when he have
conversations like i don't sleep
anything in the rug my rug is clean you
can lift it up any time because i just
air things all like i'm very open
communicator but i think some people
think that that's
the open communication is almost
offensive where it's like well let's
just sleep it in the rug let it go that
type of thing but your rug builds up
if you just sweep things under the rug
for years and years and years you get to
the point
where you've got so much built up
resentment and such an unhealthy dynamic
because you didn't your point deal with
things
when they were happening and it becomes
it
it becomes very unhealthy well we talk
about and you help teach this too we're
teaching in entree leadership is
with a team member that's misbehaving or
that is not performing
or whatever if you you know in the name
of being nice
sweep it on the rug don't deal with it
eventually
it uh you know it's going to explode
because it's going to get bad enough
that that and you finally get so
frustrated they don't even know you're
frustrated
right did you just walk in mad and fire
them didn't you tell didn't you tell a
story one time that you got fired you
still don't know why
yeah i did i'll probably destroy you dig
into that
i probably deserved it you know yeah but
uh uh but i'll never know
the guy's dead now it was a long time
ago just out of college you know
but he just walked in and cussed at me
and threw a box on my table and said get
your
blankety blank blank stuff and blankety
out of here and i'm like what i do
i don't you don't even want to know just
get out of here and i'm just like my god
well i don't know i still don't know but
um
i know he was a jerk i know that part
but i i but that doesn't mean i wasn't
right that doesn't mean i didn't deserve
it but the point is you let things build
up and so we always use the saying
when you're dealing with team members or
in and it applies in these other
other parts of this discussion too to be
unclear is to be unkind
to not uh deal with whatever there is
there and put it out there and go this
is this is what's going on yeah and this
is the way this is
what i would say to anybody listening
right now that they is something's
coming to mind whether it's in their
marriage or
in their job or whatever and they're
going oh yeah i really you know i really
hate that i don't even want to deal with
it i don't face it
fast forward 30 years what's that going
to look like if you don't you know what
i mean
that it's not going to go away it's not
going to magically things don't
magically just get better
they get better with a lot of hard work
and intentionality it was kind of like
what you're talking about a minute ago
because
there's this gap between our intentions
that we have and the outcomes that we
get and what fills the gap is discipline
or not
you're either working on it and growing
like the garden example or it's dying
and so if you don't have that
intentional discipline
to act on your intentions not just oh i
know i should read a book oh i know i
should go to counseling oh i know i
should work
no one doesn't do anything it's not the
thought that counts it's what you do
that counts that leads to the outcomes
and
i intend to send my wife flowers and i
don't i get no credit for that
it's not bragging about what you thought
about doing for her in y'all's
anniversary
it's what you actually do yeah that
counts you know this is reminding me
because sharon palooza is coming up her
birthday is in
uh and our first date was in february
her birthday's in february and so is
valentine's day so february is pretty
much sharon palooza so
i better get my act together i better
get i better get some stuff going right
now
it's not the thought that counts yeah
that's what you do it's the thought that
cats
no it's not nobody cares what you
thought about
i intended to send you flowers you get
no credit for that no
i intended to dot dot dot you get no
credit for that you're not bragging
about what your kids thought about
getting on the report card no
it's what they actually get and so i
think there's a great message here
there's a great message this
intentionality you know i'll give you a
real a true story example so the
beginning of this year
dave matt and i sat down we worked on
all of our goals what are our priorities
for the year what do we want to focus on
what are the trips we want to take
you know who do we want to be how do we
want to just improve individually and
separate whatever well one of the things
i wrote down this is me being a real
honest right now
i just want to be kinder you know i i
want to be just just kinder in general i
want to practice kindness
and so not me
[Laughter]
i'm all about that he's least really i'm
gonna add that to your list for you when
you're not looking
okay all right so i wrote this down so
true story i wrote this down and i'm
like yes this is my intention okay i
want to be kinder and here's the things
that's what we're gonna focus on
next day i was getting so frustrated
about something
and i just felt like the anger rising it
was something at the house something
with the kids and i found myself just
like getting real frustrated and i felt
the lord stirring me
are you just gonna think about being
kinder or are you gonna actually take
this moment to practice
doing what you said you wanted to do are
you going to give up your right to be
right are you going to give up your
right to be angry
and instead of stomping downstairs and
having a big fit about whatever you
think you have the right to be mad at
are you going to actually do something
about what you said you're going to do
and it was like this moment of
because in in in theory everything
sounds good
but in real life of having to walk out
some of the things having to deal with
those things that were sweeping under
the rug
act out kindness it's hard it's hard
but that's what produces the results
that's what produces the marriage that's
what produces the outcome
project the current trajectory
of that section of your life out 50
years and see where it's taking you
you may need some adjustments i think we
all might
that's my reminder from that that that's
the the reminder i got out of that
the anti-mentor this is the dave ramsey
show